the bat in the cat it's got a nice ring
the chemistry test between you all was
so
intense i think what made it intense was
that we were on well i was auditioning
for a batman movie i felt like i was
still auditioning yeah actually the
chemistry test might have been the
easiest part of making the batman
hardest part the costumes it would take
like two people helping me get in and
out of that thing and with the nails too
they kept on getting caught on things it
started very awkward
we did a lot of scenes in them
and the rain and uh trying to put on
waterproof or like insulated suit which
doesn't even keep the water out no it
holds the water it means it holds
freezing cold it holds the water closer
to you longer
oh take it easy sweetheart but the
biggest transformation in the movie
that's in theaters today colin farrell
turning into oswald cobblepot aka the
penguin after four hours in the makeup
chair co-stars paul dano jeffrey wright
and john tutturo didn't even recognize
him on set i didn't know it was coming i
had no idea what's going on
i was jealous
i was like oh man that is good i
literally walked right past him it's
like you know where's colin
oh bro
when i saw what i was going to look like
i didn't know that when i signed on to
do the film i had no idea that that's
the direction we were going so we did a
makeup test in burbank a few months
before we started shooting and i was
just
it was so much fun
[Music]